all right here's the trivia question
your friend kurt warner turns 49 today
happy birthday kurt
which wide receiver duo did kurt warner
throw more touchdown passes to isaac
bruce and tori holt or larry fitzgerald
and anquan bolden which of the two wow
first off happy birthday to my lowe's
commercial buddy okay kurt warner there
um but
man i feel like you're this might be a
trick question but i'm gonna go with
isaac bruce and tori holt even though
i'm a little scared that this is a trick
question
it's not a trick question it's a
straight question you just you just fell
into the trap it's not the guys that you
would think he was with fitzgerald and
bolton together uh long enough to have
66 touchdown passes bruce and hold it
was only 40. and remember the difference
with the rams they had marshall faulk
more guys yeah the cardinals didn't have
a guy like that the ball got spread
around more with those rams teams the
greatest show-offs on turf with with the
cardinals in 2008 2007 2006 and really
he made it through the 2009 season those
guys were both there and they caught a
lot of touchdown passes all right we we
posed that question because the draft
today is best current receiving duos in
the nfl i get the first pick this is not
an easy one to do but i'm i've got to go
with mike evans and chris godwin of the
tampa bay buccaneers when you look at
what they did last year even though they
had a quarterback who threw 30
interceptions and now this year with tom
brady there you know mike evans one of
the most overlooked players in all of
football uh we did a draft on friday of
guys that would benefit from a change of
scenery and maybe mike evans should have
been on the list although
with tom brady in tampa he's fine yeah
i'm not this year
right we we just we just
don't pay attention to evans the way we
should he's one of the best receivers in
the game and chris godwin uh stepped up
and and joined that
upper echelon of receivers last year
chris
yes yes he did and it's a special tandem
that would have been my number one pick
you know i mean you every i i echo
everything you said i mean michael mike
evans is special
you know i go back there's not a lot of
guys on planet earth that are 6'5 230
and run 437 and then can cut the way he
can cut and then godwin as one of the
special slot receivers in football
is also rare because he's awesome on the
outside too so if like the bucks want to
play like two running backs one tight
end and two receivers it's not like
chris godwin's gonna be like oh no i
have to play outside i'm not in the slot
i won't be able to get open no he's a
threat that way too so
both guys uh are really special i and i
think that's why brady picked them and
uh it's a good pick by you okay i think
i
you know hey one of these guys gets
injured a little bit but i still got to
go with tyree kill and sammy watkins as
the next best duo i mean again i know
that like sammy watkins you can't depend
on him to be there for probably six to
eight games a year but when he's it when
he's there
this is i think you could argue this is
a more dangerous duo than the one we
just talked about in tampa you know
obviously the production's not there and
the health isn't there but tyree kill to
me is still the number one weapon in all
of football on the offensive side of the
ball you know that's not a quarterback
you know i don't think there's anybody
that's more of a game changer really on
the offensive side of the ball right now
than tyree killed the attention he
creates you know what he can do
not only catching the ball and running
deep down the field but the reverses the
screens the speed sweeps and sami
watkins you know similar in that nature
i mean they're game breakers we saw that
in the playoffs this year it's just
these are two guys that if they get a
step on you see you start up the you
know strike up the band start playing
and start playing the music they're
going to score touchdowns so to me this
is the most dangerous duo in all of
football maybe not quite as productive
as your duo but more dangerous
and and the window is closing on that
duo this year you get the feeling that
sammy watkins will move on after this
season it's the last year of his
contract he took a significant pay cut
he can make a lot of the money back
in incentives but they've got mikol
hardman
coming through the pipeline and they're
just going to have to be careful what
they spend on positions other than the
quarterback as they get closer and
closer to the mega deal that they likely
will be signing sooner rather than later
with patrick mahomes all right i'm going
to go back to the nfc south
but i'm not going to go to the team that
you think i'm going to go to i'm going
to a team where the duo has never even
played together on the same team before
but there they are in new orleans
michael thomas and emmanuel sanders what
an addition sanders is to i mean michael
thomas alone is better than
75 percent of the receiving duos in the
nfl right i take him over two guys any
day you put michael thomas with emmanuel
sanders that puts them at the top of the
heap of the best receiving duos even
though they've never played together at
any time in their careers
no i mean i hear you they're on my list
i mean uh michael thomas as we know is
you know one of the best guys in the
game certainly emmanuel sanders
certainly really good
you know but i don't know if he's like
prime time anymore
i think there's some better duos out
there you know so that's that's where
this is where i win the draft baby this
is where i do it right take over but go
ahead yeah i'm who you got i'm gonna go
ahead yeah be quiet shut up i'll do my
own pick when i'm ready here we go i'm
taking i'm taking jarvis landry and obj
i am for 20 20 seasons
guys
what a surprise hey there's not a lot of
uh dubos out there that both had a
thousand yards receiving last year and
either neither one was completely
healthy so yes even though
they haven't been in like the superstar
stratosphere as far as like last year
was concerned and what they did and
odell yeah he's been dealing with
injuries really the last two years it's
been three years since we've seen him be
like real special special so i think
that's coming this year and i still
think these two guys are two of the most
physically gifted guys in the sport
landry and odell both can do it all slot
receiver outside throw passes reverse
everything they block in the run game uh
so if i'm a quarterback this would
certainly be one of my favorite duos and
i'd want to play play with them any day
all right now it gets very interesting
for the next duo
do i do i make my draft a clean sweep of
the nfc south do i dare do that and go
julio jones and calvin ridley
i'm looking around i'm looking i'm
looking i'm you know what i
um uh
i'm not i'm not going to do it i'm not
going to do it you know check in are you
checking no no no because deandre
hopkins and larry fitzgerald are
teammates now and even though fitzgerald
is far closer to the end in the
beginning he is still a great receiver
and he's going to be even better now
that he's never going to have to worry
about being double-teamed because
they're going to be draping themselves
all over deandre hopkins to try to slow
him down larry fitzgerald who is in
position to make a final assault on the
all-time records for
mainly yardage and catches uh catches
more than anything else i think is the
one he's in best position to get
he's going to have a chance this year
because they're going to be obsessed
when they face the cardinals with
stopping deandre hopkins yeah i would i
would think that larry fitz's stats
certainly aren't going to be hurting
because of the deandre hopkins actor you
know yeah larry fitzgerald still really
good
you know we know that you know game
breaker no but has value as far as size
jump ball
can still play in the slot and hopkins
for my money arguably is the best
receiver in football right there with
tyree kill i think i would probably put
tyree kill one deandre hopkins number
two right now in the nfl just from what
we've seen the last two years so i get
you there mike you know you're going
with a proven guy and somebody that's
old
i'm gonna go
a little bit of a proven guy
with somebody that yeah we haven't even
seen it on the field yet i'm going to
marry cooper and cd lamb all right
that's it yeah i don't care that i
haven't seen it happen yet wow i think
cd lamb is one of the was the best
receiver in the draft i think he's made
for the nfl of course i think amari
cooper is special explosive deep balls
great route runner i'm calling that to
be one of the best duos in football for
this year uh because i'm i think both
those guys are ballers
wow that's gutsy a guy who's never
played in the nfl we have no idea what
he's going to do how many first round
receivers have been flat-out busts now i
know lam lam shouldn't have been on the
board when he was and it was an easy
call for the cowboys it was kind of that
same randy moss slide from 1998 but
still i'm always leery about a
completely unproven guy because there's
a ceiling there's a ceiling and you
never know where that ceiling is going
to be over a given player especially at
the receiver position all right we still
have julio jones and calvin ridley on
the board but but i have two teams from
the nfc south already i'm going to the
afc west
keenan allen and mike williams
oh that's a good one they were on my
list too yeah awesome i mean you got
size and then you got a route running
extraordinaire you know and those two so
wow
i didn't think you were gonna leave
i gotta go julio jones and calvin ridley
then i do i just didn't think you were
gonna leave them there he totally
shocked me uh i thought you were gonna
pick them and then i was probably i
think i was gonna go like cooper cup and
robert woods as my next pick but julio
jones still one of the five best
receivers in football calvin ridley
awesome can do it all would we like to
see a little bit more
super stardom out of him certainly yes
uh but i think he is the next guy to
take over for julio there and be that
go-to guy for matt ryan but i think
that's a dangerous duo a lot of good
duos in football and we're not even
including some of these tight ends that
are out there too mike
and and everyone on my list made it to
the draft except one dk metcalf and
tyler locket that's the one i had nine
and that's the one that didn't make it
but that's one to keep an eye on as
metcalf continues to improve and lock it
one of the underrated receivers in the
nf
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports